finally the rubble is being removed
it's been more than two weeks since a
ceasefire was declared in gaza
after israeli forces bombarded the strip
officials here don't have the resources
or machinery to do this job on their own
so egypt sent an eight-convoy of diggers
cranes
and trucks to help with the huge task of
clearing debris
and what's left of people's homes
we asked the donor parties to provide us
with help and egypt has carried out the
support by providing the necessary
machinery
and crews to assist the removal of at
least 200 000 tons of rubble
that obstructed the movement of people
and transport
the removal of rubble means the
beginning of the reconstruction process
for many families here
muhammad amin al-kholek who lost members
of his family
and his building didn't wait for the
egyptian machinery to arrive
he hired a private crane operator to
remove the rubble from his destroyed
home
i heard that the machinery arrived but
i'm in a hurry to rebuild my home so i
brought my own contractor to speed up
the removal of the rubble
i demand the speeding up of the
reconstruction process
for the families who have been displaced
from their homes
muhammad lost his store and source of
livelihood when israel's
military targeted one of the buildings
nearby
now he has no source of income to feed
his family
i owned an electric shop that was
targeted in the israeli attacks
i have hope that with the arrival of the
egyptian machinery
the rubble will be cleared soon and my
shop will be rebuilt
i really hope it doesn't take too long
it was a short but devastating war it
killed hundreds of people
and injured thousands more many have
been displaced
hundreds of palestinian families here in
gaza are now homeless
after israel destroyed their homes last
month
all is left for them to do now is wave
in the hopes
of rebuilding what's lost when we see it
al jazeera gaza